but first breaking overnight the parents
of a teenager who's accused of carrying
out a deadly shooting at a michigan high
school are under arrest after eluding
law enforcement for several hours james
and jennifer crumley were caught in
detroit shortly after police got a tip
from someone who recognized the
crumley's car
prosecutors filed involuntary
manslaughter charges against the couple
earlier on friday their son ethan is
accused of killing four classmates and
wounding seven other people on tuesday
at oxford high school which is 30 miles
north of detroit the couple was arrested
early this morning after that tip led
detroit police to a commercial building
where the crumleys were hiding police
say the couple was not armed at the time
of their arrest michael george is
outside the oakland county jail in
michigan where the parents are being
held this morning michael good morning
dana good morning as you mentioned james
and jennifer crumbly right now are here
behind bars at the oakland county jail
the manhunt ended around 2 a.m this
morning when a detroit business owner
called 9-1-1 saying he saw their car and
a woman in his parking lot police
arrived and after a search they arrested
the couple now their attorney told
authorities they plan to turn themselves
in but the u.s marshals consider them
fugitives prosecutors say their actions
directly contributed to that deadly
school shooting
the facts of this case are so egregious
oakland county prosecutor karen mcdonald
expressed her astonishment at the events
that led up to the shooting at oxford
high school saying the actions of ethan
crumley's parents went far beyond
negligence
any individual
who had the opportunity
to stop
this tragedy
should have done so mcdonald offered new
details into tuesday's shooting
revealing that ethan was with his father
on black friday when the gun was
purchased and that ethan and his mother
had made social media posts about it
ethan just got my new beauty today and
jennifer crumbly writing over
thanksgiving weekend that it was a quote
mom and sunday testing out his new
christmas present school officials
became concerned on monday a day before
the shooting when a teacher saw ethan
crumbly searching for ammunition on his
phone his mother was contacted by the
school but phone records show she told
her son in a text message quote l.o.l
i'm not mad at you you have to learn not
to get caught
on the day of the shooting prosecutors
say a teacher found a note on ethan
crumley's desk depicting violent images
and messages in another section of the
note was a drawing of a bullet with the
following words above that bullet quote
blood everywhere further down the
drawing are the words quote my life is
useless end quote and to the night right
of that are the words quote the world is
dead crumbly's parents were summoned to
the school and told to get him into
counseling within 48 hours they resisted
the idea of taking him home the
15-year-old returned to class and
prosecutors say he then carried out the
shooting upon hearing the news of the
shooting jennifer crumley texted her son
saying ethan don't do it james crumbly
called 9-1-1 to say that a gun was
missing from their home and that his son
might be the shooter i expect parents
and everyone to to have humanity and and
to step in
and and stop stop a potential tragedy
and the crumblies are each facing four
counts of involuntary manslaughter under
michigan law those charges can be
brought if prosecutors believe they
contributed to a situation with a high
chance of harm or death they're facing
arraignment today michelle
michael's shocking details on that thank
you so much